rvffs who chose today's book are three
incredible high school students who
helped launch a groundbreaking magazine
i've had it on my desk for the last few
months it's called pass the spatula
which celebrates trailbraising chefs of
color take a look my name is chael and
i'm 18 years old i am the co-creative
director of pasa spatula magazine
my name is anthony and i am 18 years old
i am the marketing
pr and social media manager for the
magazine hello my name is chris and i am
17 years old i was a recipe developer
and interviewer
for past spatula i go to food and
finance high school and my peers and i
helped to create a spatula magazine last
year class a spatula is a spin on pasta
mic
is a student-run magazine created to
highlight past present
and future chefs of color oftentimes
chefs of color usually go unrecognized
and we want to do our best
to uplift them we honor these chefs of
color in different ways by showing
recipes
by showing their stories and showcasing
what they've done in the past and how we
can move on from that in the future
my main goal is to just bring the
message to past a spatula
throughout the world this is all
something that we're passionate about
even as high school students we can have
an impact
it's a very well done magazine please
welcome
chai yell anthony and chris
i'm so geeking out i've literally been
such a lover of your magazine i can't
believe i'm meeting you it is such a
huge accomplishment
what you guys have made what have um
each of you personally learned
from this experience chael i'd love to
start with you
yeah so for me i know this experience
has been you know
a really good eye opener and i know for
me um you kind of look at this
experience and say i have a voice you
know it's not just someone who has a
degree someone who has a title
even if it's just like something small
that you've written i didn't write like
a whole you know bunch in the magazine
but
even that small little blurb i've
written even that small little drawing
that i did
i know it has an impact on somebody's
life it really does
and um anthony how has it been for you
yeah this experience has been really
incredible
i mean you know going into this magazine
we honestly didn't know what
a magazine was supposed to be like we
didn't know what the process of creating
a magazine was so by going into this
um magazine we were exposed to such a
plethora of different opportunities
and really it just opened up the
possibilities of food
for me and my future career chris how
has it been for you so this magazine
shows that anything can happen
especially during a pandemic on top of
that on top of that we have the great
message to show
that black chefs do matter and do need a
voice and especially the spotlight
so especially it was definitely great
especially during the trying times
well i agree completely
and i just love the cookbook that you
picked for today's club it's mix tape
pock lock
by quest love i have to tell you i am
his biggest fan and this book is set up
like a dinner party
are you guys a fan of this format why
did you bring it to the club
chael yes definitely i know for me you
know when you go through cookbooks it's
probably like all
soups or like all salmon like okay i
love you a good soup
i want to get a little bit of everything
like i want to get an appetizer an
entree a dessert
and everything is in this book it's
something that you know
you can see things that you've never
seen before um and another thing i love
about this book is that there's music to
pair along with it so
good food good tunes is a great
experience it's just amazing
you can't have a dinner party without
music it would be blasphemy and i love
getting the opportunity to learn
from these talented chefs and one of the
chefs in the cookbook
is kwame onwatchee and you also featured
him in past the spatula and
chris you wrote an article and a recipe
inspired by him why is he such a role
model for you
so from his upbringing to where he is
now which is head chef
it definitely shows that anything can
come true with hard work
and being able being able to know
interview him and create the jollof rice
with jerk chicken
definitely encap encapulates who he is
as a person
i have been such a kwami fan for so long
because i haven't missed one
frame of top chef
[Music]
you